هذه الاقدام تقاوم قسوه الحصول على لقمه
العيش اكتاف هؤلاء الرجال تحمل من الالام
ما لا يطيقه بشر
يحاوطون هذه البحيره الفيروزيه بحثا عن
ذهب الشيطان في بركان ايجن الواقع في
زاويه نائيه من جزيره جاوا الشرقيه في
اندونيسيا
يغامر هؤلاء العمال بحياتهم من اجل بضعه
دولارات في مهمه تبدو لكثير منا شبه
مستحيله يصعدون وينزلون على طرق وعره من
والى بركان النيران هو زرقاء ودرجه حرارته
تتخطى 600 درجه مئويه
وكل ذلك من اجل جلب هذا الكبريت الاصفر او
ذهب الشيطان كما يطلقون عليه هناك
سوف
[موسيقى]
انظر كفر الوان
عمال بركان ايجن ان تمكنوا من الهروب من
خطر ثوران الحمم البركانيه لن يهرب من
الامراض المزمنه فهذه البحيره ذات اللون
الفيروزي واحده من اكبر البحيرات الحمضيه
على كوكب الارض وتنبعث منها غازات شديده
السميه اصابت الكثير من العمال وسكان
المنطقه بامراض مزمنه وادت في بعض الحالات
الى الوفاه ما دفع بعض المنظمات المدافعه
عن حقوق العمال لتصنيف هذه المهنه على
انها اخطر مهنه في العالم
اذا لم تكنو يعطي انخفا
فالانتدلاع عنود
عنتر جريب
تبدا رحله رجال ذهب الشيطان بقطع نحو
اربعه كيلو مترات على شفا حفره الكبريت
واسفل البركان بظهور منحنيه واياد عاريه
دون اي قفازات او ملابس تحميهم من خطر
الغازات السامه يحملون عشرات الكيلوجرامات
من الكبريت في سلال بدائيه عائدين بها الى
مكان انطلاقهم وكل ذلك مقابل سبعه دولارات
الى ثمانيه في اليوم فقط
ذلك
في اندونيسيا يوجد اكثر من 75 بركان نشطا
ومنطقه بركان ايجن محاطه بقيوم صفراء
نتيجه بعض الاتربه المحمله بالكبريت ومعظم
عمال المناجم هناك يعانون من سعال مزمن
واسنان صفراء لكن ظروف الحياه الصعبه قد
تفرض علينا احيانا خيارات قاسيه حتى لو
كانت على حساب الصحه الجسديه